the problem of Islamic fundamentalism
has been with us quite a long time and
it has been growing and it has come to
the fore in recent acts of terrorism
which we saw in the trade centres at
about 1993 so with acts of terrorism
against our ship
9/11 and there is a growing sense under
the broad category of jihad where the
Muslim world feels the necessity to
assert itself and add its values they
did not like our way of life they do not
like the way we treat women women are
very different in their society they do
not like the way our women dress and it
is an evolving problem stemming largely
or significantly from problems in the
Mideast